hey David in light of the Brett
Kavanaugh fiasco
should it simply not be up to the
President to nominate Supreme Court
justices we've been asked about supreme
court justice of appointment processes
in the past but I think that this takes
on a very particular tone given that
it's Donald Trump
and it's serial accused sexist alter and
totally unhinged perjurer
Brett Kavanaugh in this particular case
I can come up with a whole bunch of
other ways that we could determine who
becomes the next Supreme Court pick the
next Supreme Court justice that don't
involve the president saying here's who
I nominate and the Senate saying we
either vote to confirm or we don't there
are all sorts of things we could come up
with public votes of different kinds a
campaign of sorts it doesn't matter but
I want to make a different point I would
be okay with the president continuing to
appoint Supreme Court justices judges
they become justices they don't actually
have to be judges but typically they are
I would be much more okay with the
system we have where the president just
gets to pick because it is in a way
simple symbols aren't always the best if
and here's the most important thing we
had term limits on the Supreme Court
such that it was predictable and
scheduled how many Supreme Court
justices each presidential term has
assigned to it and when it takes place
because think about that for a second a
lot of the problems we have right now
are Obama had the opportunity to appoint
someone Merrick garland it was the last
year of his presidency and Republicans
to their credit successfully held it up
with the idea that we want to hear from
the people first before we make any
appointments for life we want to hear
from the people first and they were able
to delay that we now have a situation
where Anthony Kennedy was involved in
negotiations he wanted to make sure that
it would be kavanah or someone else from
his list that was going to get selected
so he ended up making a deal to leave
now instead of maybe after Donald Trump
is out of office for example we solve a
lot of these problems and make it much
simpler and cleaner if we say hey nine
justices
they each get 12 year terms meaning that
eventually I think that means if you do
it on a rolling basis every presidential
term I don't know what ready NASA you
would make the math work and that way
you know listen this election is
important not because for Supreme Court
justices might retire or might die or
might make a deal it's we know that two
Supreme Court justices are going to be
replaced in the next term the next
president is going to get two of those
appointments we know which ones they are
and that way voters know okay well let's
see two liberal Supreme Court justices
are going to be hitting there or they're
gonna be maxing out and are going to be
replaced it's extra important if we
don't want the court to move to the
right to not vote for a Republican in
this particular election that would be a
much better solution yeah I like this
approach especially because it has way
too much to do with luck right now yes
like Bush got to appointees Obama got to
should he got three but he got to
Trump's two years into his presidency he
already has two appointees like how is
that how is that fair how is that
democratic apps and also this approach
is better because it doesn't blow up the
entire balance of power that we have
right so like when it has to do with we
talk about legislation legislative
branch rights and passes the bill the
executive branch signs it and the
judiciary
holds up whether or not it's
constitutional sure the check that the
executive branch currently has on the
judicial branch is that the president
picks the Supreme Court justices yes so
electing them or having Congress choose
them I think it would just kind of kind
of shake up the balance of power and I
don't necessarily want to do that if we
don't have to it would be a much more
serious up ending of what we have then
simply saying there are term limits and
the justices are on a schedule and we
know exactly who's retiring when because
that's when they hit the end of their
term send me your thoughts if you have
other ideas about this